Hello and welcome to this episode of
What's Up Prof.
Hi Martin, what are you doing in such a
peculiar set? Yes, I
had to
get away from the studio for a while.
Oh, I see. So, this is an improvisation.
That's it. We didn't expect it to
happen, but So, what happened? Some
unforeseen things happen sometimes.
Yes.
Let's get into it and open with a word
of prayer.
Our heavenly Father, thank you
that we can
do your work
from anywhere.
Thank you for the interesting times that
we live in.
Thank you for giving us the opportunity
to do discussions like these. We ask
that you now enlighten our minds
and guide us and
with the Holy Spirit in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
Now Martin, there were some people that
were not very happy that we didn't speak
about the war in Israel.
Yeah. What is your your answer to that
one? Well, I think people must now after
so long realize that we're not a news
agency, we're not MSM, mainstream media.
We are putting signs of the times
together and putting it into biblical
prophecy. I see. Okay. And
the war is fascinating and it's
interesting.
And it's definitely worth a mention.
Yeah.
So, we will we will mention it. We will
mention it, but it doesn't have a lot to
do with
Bible prophecy being fulfilled. Correct.
So, let's have a look at the title,
which is war in Israel.
Zionists versus Islam.
A holy war or a Jesuit agenda.
Now Martin, that's a very provocative
title.
And the reason why it's provocative is
because it's based on historic facts.
Mhm.
Uh the Protestant Reformation very
distinctly identified
the Antichrist.
And Martin Luther and all the reformers
that were contemporaries and thereafter
like Melanchthon or Tyndale or
thereafter the Wesleys or whoever they
were
whether it was John Knox in Scotland or
wherever, they all had one tune to sing.
The Antichrist was alive and well and
living in Rome. Yeah.
And Martin Luther wrote a tract called
The Babylonian Captivity
in which he explained that the
Babylonian system was really ensconced
in Rome.
And all eyes should be on Rome. That's
it.
Now the papacy couldn't afford that. No.
Because that would expose them for what
they were. And why were were they called
the Antichrist system? It's because they
worked directly against Christ.
They banned the word.
And Jesus is the word, right?
That's it.
They distorted the word. They changed
the word. They changed the law. They did
all of these things.
And Martin Luther identified them. They
were against the atonement. Mhm.
Isn't that a very serious issue? Well,
that
if you don't accept the atonement You
can't go to
You can't go to heaven.
You get rid of the entire plan of
salvation.
And they focused all the attention on
man
rather than on God. The attention should
be where it belongs. It should belong to
God because redemption is outside of us.
Yeah. It is an act that God undertook in
his mercy towards us. And to write him
out of the equation is an Antichrist
activity.
So, the Jesuits came up with a plan
of getting rid of the idea that the
papacy was the Antichrist.
And they invented two directions
diametrically opposed to each other. The
one was preterism and the other one was
futurism. Now we've dealt with this many
many times.
Now preterism put the Antichrist in the
past. And they said that Antiochus
Epiphanes, a Greek king
was the Antichrist. But that's
ridiculous
because according to Daniel, the
Antichrist comes out of the fourth
beast, which is Rome.
So, it cannot be a Greek king Antiochus
Epiphanes IV.
And
in spite of this, many Protestant
denominations swallowed that lie.
They drank some Babylonian wine. Yeah.
Does that sound familiar? Does it link
up with the three angels' messages?
Definitely. The second one maybe?
one.
Okay.
to that as well. We'll have to work on
these things because everything that's
happening
is in the three angels' messages. Yes.
And then they came up with futurism.
The Antichrist will come in the future.
They expanded it a little bit and
created
a a whole scenario. An anti-prophetic
scenario.
And Cardinal Bellarmine, also a Jesuit
uh embellished it somewhat.
And according to this philosophy, the
Antichrist would come sometime in the
future.
And of course, they claimed that the
Antichrist would manifest himself in the
temple of God, in a physical temple
built of stone.
But it's very clear in scripture that
the temple, the new temple of God is
God's church.
"Uh ye are the temple of the living
God," claims Paul.
So, this whole scenario implies that a
temple must be built.
Now if a temple must be built, Martin
then there must be a nation to build it.
Yes.
And therefore, a plan was put in motion
to create the nation of Israel.
And also to create Zionism.
Now Zionism is a political movement
whereby Israel again receives national
recognition as a nation with a physical
territory over which they can rule. And
that of course has to be the same
territory more or less where ancient
Israel was.
And this plot was put into operation in
after the Second World War. There were
many preparations
in order to achieve this.
And this is a Jesuit agenda.
So, what we are seeing is actually an
occult agenda. Yes, not biblical. Not a
biblical agenda.
Everybody is reading portions in their
Bible that says God will gather his
nation from out of all the scattered
countries.
That's meaning the spiritual Israel.
Which means every person that accepts
Jesus. That is the people that is
gathered together, not the physical
nation. Correct. Remember that we said
that the last period
for humanity comes after the cross.
Yeah.
And there people have to either accept
Jesus or reject him.
And there's no other name under heaven
whereby we may be saved except the name
Christ Jesus.
So, when we look at this war, we have to
look behind the scenes. People believe
that there are two streams of activity
in God's plan. And we've dealt with that
before as well in a What's Up Prof.
And that the one stream says that there
is a a stream which revolves around the
church.
And then there is a stream which
revolves around literal Israel. And
that's called dispensationalism.
And that also has its origin with the
Jesuits. That's it.
So, it's a distraction. It's a
distraction. We have to focus on what
biblical prophecy says. And for that, we
have to watch two entities. The beast
out of the sea and the beast out of the
earth. That's it. Is the beast out of
the sea
and the beast out of the earth involved
in all of these activities.
Yes. Yes, the one is the spiritual arm,
the other one is a military arm.
But it is a spiritual distraction to
keep people off the true path.
Many years ago, Martin, when I did Total
Onslaught,
I did a lecture called Revolutions,
Tyrants, and Wars.
Mhm.
Where we looked at all of these
activities that were going on.
And we see that the Jesuits were
fermenting wars and revolutions, etc. No
wonder they were thrown out of virtually
every country in the world, right? For a
while. Yes.
And then there was this interesting
letter by Albert Pike,
which he wrote to Mazzini.
Now, there's there's a lot of talk about
this letter, and many claim that there
would never was such a letter.
But there are too many sources,
unfortunately, for these people to
collaborate it.
And then it was also apparently in the
British Museum, and then it was taken
away.
Let's just read some of the things that
pertain to this issue.
So, this is the letter by Albert Pike,
the 33-degree Freemason, the grand
master,
who wrote Morals and Dogma.
And it states, "The First World War must
be brought about in order to permit the
Illuminati to overthrow the power of the
Tsars in Russia,
and making that country a fortress of
atheistic communism. The divergence is
caused by the agentur agents of the
Illuminati between the British and
German empires will be used to ferment
this war, and at the end of the war,
communism will be built and used to
destroy the other governments,
and in order to weaken religions."
Now, Martin, let's just reflect if that
happened.
Yes.
To a T. To a T, right? And the
Illuminati, who founded them? Wasn't it
Adam Weishaupt?
Weishaupt. A Jesuit. Wasn't he a Jesuit?
They say he was an ex-Jesuit. But,
Martin, an ex-Jesuit is a dead Jesuit.
Yes. So, they like to put the Jesuits in
a position where they go underground,
apparently wrote against their own
institution. And then eventually,
they turn them into heroes.
Do we have another example? Yes, we do.
What about Pierre Teilhard de Chardin?
The man who was responsible for the
Piltdown hoax,
the evolutionary one.
Yeah. The one who was the philosophical
father of the United Nations. Mhm. He
was a guru there, as it were. He was
almost worshipped for his philos-
philosophies.
But he was so radical that the church
distanced themselves from him.
But after his death and in recent times,
they wrote articles
glorifying him. So, Martin, he did a
good job.
He brought mysticism into the United
Nations. And then you had these
organizations such as the Temple of
Understanding and all of these, and
these organizations that use the
writings of Blavatsky and Alice A.
Bailey, and their agendas for 2025,
the externalization of the hierarchy.
Why are these official United Nations
organizations?
Because it's part of an agenda. It's
part of an agenda. And who's always the
father behind it? It's a Jesuit. It's a
Jesuit. It's a Jesuit agenda.
And did they break down religion? Yes.
Especially in with the First World War
in Russia. Correct. And Pierre Teilhard
de Chardin with the Piltdown hoax was
pushing
was pushing the agenda of evolution.
And Karl Marx and Lenin and all of these
people were probably controlled by the
same powers
and put these ideas into the world. And
they were occult.
Because they belonged to organizations
like the Ghostly Guild,
where they communicated with demons.
All right. So, basically,
this actually happened. That's it.
Exactly like it was
Well, let's say prophesied by them, by
the occult. Yes, because Satan also has
a counter-prophecy, and he must give it
enough credence
so that people will actually believe it.
And I'm afraid a great portion of the
evangelical world has swallowed this
bait hook, line, and sinker. They're on
the road of dispensationalism.
They're waiting for an Antichrist in the
future. Excuse me,
do they remember their roots, where they
come from? Do they study the issues as
to why the papacy is the Antichrist, or
are they sitting in ecumenical councils?
They're all in ecumenical councils.
Okay. The Second World War
must be fermented by taking advantage of
the differences between the fascists and
the political Zionists.
This war must be brought about so that
Nazism is destroyed, and that the
political Zionism be strong enough to
institute a sovereign state of Israel in
Palestine. During the Second World War,
international communism must become
strong enough in order to balance
Christendom, which would be then
restrained and held in check until the
time when we would need it for the final
social cataclysm.
Did this happen, Martin? Exactly like
that.
And one wonders why the nations that
were apparently fighting against Nazism
put up naval blockades to make sure that
the Jews that came out of this
cataclysmic situation actually ended up
in Palestine.
Now, everything You see, so actually,
this is not prophetic. This is just
planned. This is planned. Yes, you can
plan prophecy.
But this has nothing to do with biblical
prophecy.
No.
And then there was to be a Third World
War.
And the Third World War
must be fermented by taking advantage of
the differences caused by the agentur of
the Illuminati between the political
Zionists and the leaders of the Islamic
world.
The war must be conducted in such a way
that Islam, the Muslim Arab world, and
political Zionism, the state of Israel,
mutually destroy each other.
Meanwhile, the other nations, once more
divided on the issues, will be
constrained to fight to the point of
complete physical, moral, and spiritual
economical exhaustion.
"We shall unleash the nihilists," wrote
Pike.
"And the atheists, and we shall provide
a formidable social cataclysm, which in
all its horror will show clearly to the
nations the effect of absolute atheism,
origin of savagery, and the most bloody
turmoil."
Luciferians don't want atheism. They are
using it as a tool.
Tool, exactly. Because they want to
worship Lucifer directly, right?
"Then everywhere, the citizens obliged
to defend themselves against the world's
minority of revolutionaries,
will exterminate those destroyers of
civilization, and the multitude,
disillusioned with Christianity,
whose theistic spirits will from that
moment be without compass or direction,
anxious for an ideal, but without
knowing where to render adoration,
will receive the true light of the
universal manifestation
of the pure doctrine of Lucifer,
brought finally out in public view."
This manifestation will result from the
general reactionary movement, which will
follow the destruction of Christianity
and atheism, both conquered and
exterminated at the same time.
Martin, this is a diabolical Luciferian
plan.
Now, many people believe that with
Desert Storm,
some of this was going into fulfillment,
but now there's another excitement
happening in the Middle East, isn't
there? Yeah. And it's creating what they
he's mentioned here,
uh
people standing behind the one and the
other from right across the world. All
right. Now, is there already a division
that has been brought about and talk of
nuclear war, for example, between Russia
and the West?
Yes. Between China and the West?
So, this has also been fermented in the
background.
So, nations have actually chosen sides.
Now, you have the BRICS nations on the
one side, and you have the Western
nations on the other side.
This divide has already been created.
Has communism played a role in this?
Yes, much so. So, not only communist
Russia, but also communist China has
been involved, and there is this divide.
Now, if you had the right powdercake
and you managed to put a match to it,
could it explode? Oh, for sure. And that
seems to be always centralized
at around Israel. All right. Now, this
is a horrible thought,
but the being a Jesuit agenda, it's a
diabolical agenda, right?
And as Spike said,
if you destroy
Christianity
and Judaism in one go
and also throw in atheism, then people
will accept Luciferianism.
Mhm.
Now, if the Christian world
has adopted this Jesuitical idea of
dispensationalism
and all their hopes are pinned on
Jerusalem and the temple and all of
these and
suddenly this goes up in smoke,
will they be disillusioned? Might be.
Very much so.
And
I was thinking now,
this is not biblical prophecy,
but it will fit into biblical prophecy
as the time of trouble such as never
was. Correct. And then
they might actually build that temple.
Yeah. And all of these things might
happen. And in during that time when
probation has closed,
Satan will be manifesting himself as a
angel of light.
That will happen. So, this Luciferian
plan of this might come into fruition.
Yes, but it'll be a counterfeit.
That's it. To keep the eyes of those who
are biblically orientated off the real
issues.
So, Martin, whether this happens or
whether it doesn't happen or whether it
blows up into a major war or whether it
doesn't, it has nothing to do with
biblical prophecy.
It is a ruse. It could be a
A rumor of wars. It could be a rumor of
wars. And there are voices that are
going up that are saying that this is a
false flag. Yeah.
Because their security in Israel is so
magnificent
that they boasted that they can see a
cockroach crossing the fence. Mhm. Let
alone an invasion as has taken place
right now. And there are many voices
that are saying this and this has
nothing to do with choosing sides. This
is merely an observation.
Yes.
Now,
Zionism.
Zionism is this movement that wants to
give Israel or the Jews a state, a
national identity, and the Jewish state.
And Zionism is not very old. No.
In fact, it is something that is
approximately 100 years old,
but it is a Jesuit agenda. And people
must remember that. The Protocols of
Zion, for example, where all the blame
is shifted to the Jews for fomenting
globalism and all of these issues is
really a Jesuit agenda. They use a front
organization
in order to appear as the innocent ones
taking care of the poor. So, everybody
is up in arms because they say that they
the Zionists sit behind the Rockefellers
and all the banking and all of this.
Correct. But once again, like you just
mentioned, that's just the front.
That's just the front organization. So,
let's ask a Jew
whether he sees Zionism as a movement
which is biblical or not.
This has nothing to do with religion.
This is not a religious conflict.
Yeah. Hundreds of years we've lived
together without the United Nations or
human rights groups to protect us. This
has nothing with religion. That is all a
ploy, a false portrayal of the state of
Israel and Zionism to legitimize what
they're doing and to gain gain support
from the world for their existence.
Judaism is a religion, a
a spirituality to serve God thousands of
years
old. Zionism is only around 100 years
old. It is the transformation from
religion to nationalism, to materialism
created by non-religious Jews who hated
the religion. And they really wouldn't
didn't want with Judaism. They didn't
even want to make their state in
Palestine only in Uganda at the first
meetings. The reason they used the names
Israel, the star of David, hijacking,
stealing the identity of Judaism and the
Jewish people is in order to
to get legitimacy for their existence
that people should say, "Oh, God gave
it's God-given to them." And that they
should put fear and intimidate people
from speaking up against their actions
because they'll call them anti-Semitic.
Yeah. There couldn't be anything further
from the truth. So, Martin, this whole
dispensation idea
that God has two purposes,
one for Israel and one for the church,
it's not biblical. No.
And the only way to salvation is to
accept Jesus Christ as your personal
savior.
So, the Jew
who has been grafted out,
cut out of the vine,
can be grafted back in according to
Paul. If he does what? Accepts Jesus as
his savior. Yes. So, Martin, what the
Jews need to do is to study the
prophecies. They must go to their book,
the Bible, the Old Testament. And they
must go and look at Daniel and they must
go and look at Daniel chapter 8 and
Daniel chapter 9. And they must study
the 70-week prophecy.
And they will understand that they
missed the boat. And all the prophecies
pertaining to the Messiah as Paul
expounded to them, but they hardened
their hearts. They would not do it. And
the same with this Orthodox Jew that we
just saw on this video.
He's got that right that the Zionist
state is all a ruse and all but he still
has to accept Jesus. He still has to
accept Jesus. Now, Martin, I was atheist
and Catholic.
Did I have to accept Jesus as my
personal savior and come out of that
system? Yes. Did I have to accept the
atonement?
Yes. Okay.
Uh does that then apply to the shaman?
To the Buddhist?
To the Hindu? Yes. To the Muslim?
There's no other name by which you can
get to heaven.
Right. So, let's see what the Spirit of
Prophecy has to say on the issue.
Meanwhile, worshipers from every nation
sought the temple
which had been dedicated to the worship
of God.
Glittering with gold and precious
stones, it was a vision of beauty and
grandeur.
But Jehovah was no longer to be found in
that palace of loveliness.
Israel as a nation
had divorced herself from God.
When Christ near the close of his
earthly ministry looked for the last
time upon the interior of the temple, he
said, "Behold, your house is left unto
you desolate."
Matthew 23:38. Hitherto,
he had called the temple his father's
house,
but as the Son of God passed out from
those walls, God's presence was
withdrawn forever from that temple built
to his glory.
So, Martin, if that is the case, this
comes from Acts of the Apostles,
is it withdrawn from a future temple as
well? Definitely. Because what is the
temple of all about? Isn't it about
sacrifice? That's it. So, isn't that a
denial of the one sacrifice that takes
away the sins of the world?
Yeah. Towards which the whole
sanctuary was showing
Yes.
in the desert. Absolutely. And what does
the word desolate mean?
Gone.
It's empty. Nothing. It's no longer of
any religious value.
The city of Jerusalem is no longer a
sacred place. This comes from the Review
and Herald.
The curse of God is upon it because of
the rejection and crucifixion of Christ.
A dark blood of guilt rests upon it and
it never again will it be a sacred place
until it has been cleansed by the
purifying fires of heaven.
At the time when this sin-cursed earth
is purified from every stain of sin,
Christ will again stand upon Mount
Olivet.
As his feet rest upon it,
it will part asunder and become a great
plain prepared for the city of God. When
does this take place? After the
millennium. Ah, because at the second
coming,
Christ doesn't come to this earth. We
meet him in the air, right?
That's it. He doesn't put his feet on
the ground. So, Martin, if that takes
place only after the millennium when it
will be hallowed by him touching Mount
Zion.
In the meantime, until then, is there
any sanctity applied to it? No. None
whatsoever.
There's a work to do for God all around
us. There is a world to save and God
calls upon us to be co-workers with him.
He calls upon us to work with
earnestness and zeal for the
unconverted. Does that include the Jew?
Yes.
Cuz he needs a conversion.
100% the same as everybody else. No. And
I
I There's also people that says, "Okay,
but especially this group or especially
the Jews or especially them." There's no
especially. Everybody has to be saved.
and
tribe and nation.
There's another quote from Early
Writings and this one is pretty direct.
They were degraded,
shunned, and detested
as if the brand of Cain were upon them.
Yet, I saw that God had marvelously
preserved this people and scattered them
over the world that they might be looked
upon as especially visited by the curse
of God.
It sounds very harsh, but what it
basically says is their nation was taken
away from them. They were scattered
throughout nations of the world. And in
a sense, Martin, because of this, they
were brought into contact with
Christianity, largely, right?
And they refused it.
They embraced certain aspects of it.
I know the Jews, for example, many in
the United States, they will celebrate
Christmas and all of these things and
the form and the and the rituals that go
along with it, but the essence they have
never ever embraced or accepted.
I saw that God had forsaken the Jews as
a nation.
But that individuals amongst them will
yet be converted and be enabled to tear
the veil from their hearts and see that
the prophecy concerning them has been
fulfilled.
They will receive Jesus as the savior of
the world and see the great sin of their
nation in rejecting and crucifying him.
Martin, this is exactly what Paul said.
They can be grafted in.
And what a marvelous situation that
would be. They have the law.
They understand God's dealings with
ancient Israel. They could be such a
power within God's church. But they must
accept the lamb of God that taketh away
the sins of the world because there is
no other way whereby we can be saved.
So, people must get away from
dispensationalism.
They must get away from futurism. It is
a Jesuit ruse.
That's it. And if we understand
Jesuitism and if we understand
Catholicism, not Catholics, because
Catholics are in the same boat. They
also have to accept the true Jesus, the
one that atones for them,
not the pope or the priest that forgives
them their sins, because who can forgive
sins but God, right?
You see, there's two
distracting streams.
The Jews
believe in the law,
but they reject Jesus. Now, you've got
the majority of the Christian world that
accepts Jesus, but rejects the law.
Absolutely.
The third angel's message is to lighten
the earth with its glory, but only those
who have witnessed temptation in the
strength of the mighty one will be
permitted to act a part in proclaiming
it when it shall have swelled into a
loud cry.
So, Martin, if you want to be part of
the final movement to bring the final
message of warning to the world,
then you have to live it.
You can't just give it lip service,
right?
And the final message to the world has
nothing to do with the literal
Jerusalem. No.
Nothing, because as a nation, they are
forever forsaken of God. We have no need
to go to Jerusalem.
We have no need to give special
attention to Jerusalem,
because special attention to one group
is neglect of other groups.
That's That's why I mentioned it
earlier. There's no especial There's no
especial.
So, what is the the message that must go
to the world? We're talking about the
three angels' messages. Right.
And the three angels' messages are a
final call to humanity. Worship God and
give glory to him as the first angel,
right?
For the hour of his judgment is come.
Okay, we will deal with all of that in
great detail. The second angel says
Babylon has fallen.
has fallen.
Now, Babylon has fallen.
And Babylon, we know, is a fallen
religious system that negates Jesus
Christ.
Even if they give in lip service, if
they negate his power, they negated
Jesus Christ and have become a fallen
Christian entity.
So, is Judaism part of Babylon? Yes.
Mhm? Mhm. Okay. Is Catholicism part of
Babylon?
Yes. It's the mother. It's the mother of
Babylon. She's the mother of harlots.
Now, the other ones that have embraced
her doctrines, that have imbibed in her
wine, her doctrine,
has the Christian world imbibed in
Jesuit doctrine?
Swallowed it completely.
and sinker. That's why we get so many
questions about literal Zionism, right?
And they then become part of Babylon.
Yes. Because they've consumed the wine.
And do they sit in ecumenical councils?
Yeah. So, do they again accept the
authority of Rome over and above the
authority of the word?
The whole time. They're having a feast
the whole time with this wine. All
right. Does the Bible say that you have
to stay aloof from the world? Yeah.
Is Catholicism aloof from the world or
is it involved in every political
organization and country in the world?
That's it. And then into merchants, that
means businesses, and in media, and in
uh movies, everything. They've got their
tentacles everywhere.
Do the rock stars and movie stars
frequent the streets of Rome and the
papacy?
Meet with the papacy on a regular basis.
Okay, is that love for God or love for
the world? Love for the world. We have
to look into that, right?
It has ever been the design of Satan to
draw the minds of people from Jesus to
man
and to destroy individual
accountability.
Satan failed in his design when he
tempted the Son of God, but he succeeded
better when he came to fallen man.
Christianity became corrupted. Popes and
priests presumed to take an exalted
position and taught the people to look
to them for pardon of their sins
instead of looking to Christ for
themselves.
Individual accountability, right?
You're not saved corporately.
You're saved as an individual.
So, you're saved as an individual. So,
there can be no national salvation,
right?
No affiliation.
Is there a once saved, always saved?
Mhm? If the righteous man turns from his
righteousness and does what is evil in
the sight of the Lord, none of his
former righteousness will be remembered.
He will surely die. Meaning eternal
death, right? Choose you this day. All
right.
And if the unrighteous man turns from
his unrighteousness and does what is
right in the sights of the Lord, none of
his former unrighteousness will be
remembered. He will live.
Isn't that what Ezekiel tells us?
And the Lord, has he changed that? Nope.
Because I am the Lord, I change not.
Isn't that what he said?
Yeah.
All right, Martin. So, these temptations
that Jesus had to endure
and where he conquered Satan, because
let's make it quite clear, during the
temptations,
Jesus actually conquered Satan.
Exactly.
He paid the price for the sin at the
cross,
but the victory over Satan took place in
the wilderness.
Because the three
basic sins of humanity into which all
other sins can be fitted
were overcome in
the wilderness of temptation. So, maybe
we should look at that, don't you think
because this is what it all is about.
And if we want to stand for what is
about to come upon this earth with a
deception and all these things that
divert our minds into different
directions,
we have to study what these temptations
were so that that Jesus can help us
overcome these things. All right.
And Martin, is it possible that the
three temptations
have a counterpart in the final message,
the three angels' messages? I'm sure if
you really study it, I'm sure we'll get
to it.
All right, because if Satan failed to
overcome
the Son of God, but was more successful
with humanity,
then those three must be somehow
have part Be part and parcel of even the
religious systems of the world, isn't
that so? You see, the thing is
it's similar to the three angels'
messages already in If you don't accept
the first angel's message, then you're
going to have problems with the second
and third.
Absolutely. You have to accept the first
before you will understand the second.
And if you do not understand the second,
you definitely will not understand the
third.
So, what will happen with the
temptations?
Huh? Same. If you don't accept don't
overcome the first,
you're going to have a problem with the
rest of them, too. And if you don't
accept the second one, will you rebel
against the third one? Definitely. Okay.
All right, let's have a look at the
temptations. Now, Matthew 4 talks about
the temptations. Interesting, Luke 4 as
well,
but Luke has them in a different
sequence.
I think the sequence as we have it in
Matthew is probably exactly how it
happened.
Then was Jesus led up of the spirit into
the wilderness to be tempted of the
devil.
The year was 27 AD, Martin.
After 4,000 years of sin.
Yeah. So.
So, 4,000 years before this, Adam and
Eve failed in this temptation these
temptations.
And Jesus overcame where they failed.
So, we have to find these temptations
also in Adam and Eve.
And we have to find them in humanity
today. That's it.
All right. And he was tempted by the
devil.
And when he had fasted 40 days and 40
nights, he was afterwards a hunger.
And when the tempter came to him, he
said, "If thou be the son of God,
command that these stones be made
bread."
But he answered and said, "It is
written, man shall not live by bread
alone, but by every word that proceedeth
out of the mouth of God."
All right, that's the first temptation.
You know, people tend to
brush over it. Mhm.
But it's a very, very serious
temptation. It was the
most serious temptation for Adam and
Eve. All right. Now, Adam and Eve were
tempted, and uh it looked good for food.
The fruit looked delicious.
And they thought that there was a
spiritual connotation also attached to
the fruit.
And they desired it.
And so, appetite
ruled their reason.
Often does appetite rule the reason of
humanity today? For sure.
And in the days of Noah, they were
eating and drinking. Now, there's no sin
in eating and drinking because God
designed it so.
It must be eating and drinking in
excess.
Mhm.
And eating and drinking that which is
not conducive to your health. According
to what God, in his all knowledge, gave.
All right. Now, if you look at the mega
companies today,
and largely who controls them? Mhm.
Mhm.
Knights of Malta organizations. And
they're all affiliated and running to
Rome in order to receive their
instructions for the latter days.
Uh these companies, do they always
provide the most healthful food to
humanity? Not at all. Or do they contain
uh compounds which confuse the mind,
such as caffeine, for example?
Uh the tea industry, the coffee
industry,
the beverage industry with caffeine and
other
uh components in it, colorants.
Uh you name it. Things that confuse the
mind.
Uh do you think this has a godly origin
or another origin? A dark origin, for
sure. Do you think it could be part of
the Babylonian confusion, or at least to
make sure that Babylon remains confused?
Definitely. So, how important is it,
Martin,
to have a health message?
It's
part of the three angels' messages. All
right.
And it took the son of God 40 days of
fasting. He was emaciated.
And in this emaciated
form,
he overcame where Adam and Eve failed
and fell, right?
Do you think that eating and drinking
will be a major temptation in the last
days? I'm sure of it. Is it part of the
three angels' messages somewhere?
Yep. And
it's the right arm of the third angel's
message. Ah, it's the right arm of the
third angel's message. And the third
angel's message warns against the mark
of the beast.
And the mark of the beast is his claim
to authority.
And his proof
of having this authority that he claims
to have, to be above the word of God,
isn't that what he says? It's exactly.
He said he changed the Sabbath to the
Sunday.
That's the proof
of his authority.
Now, doesn't it say here, "Man shall not
live by bread alone, but by every word
that proceedeth out of the mouth of
God"?
Is the first temptation
part and parcel of a warning not to
receive the direction of man,
but to take heed of the direction of
God? Perfectly. And by doing this,
you'll show where your allegiance lie.
All right. So, obedience to God. Mhm.
Uh does that imply obedience to his law?
Yes. Does he also have health laws?
Health laws?
Were there certain things that they were
not supposed to eat?
Yep. Were they ceremonial? No. No. If
you touched the dead carcass, you had to
wash yourself. Yep.
Is that a ceremonial thing, or is it to
get rid of contaminants as well? It's
just as relevant today as it was then.
Yes, you were ceremonially unclean, but
you were literally unclean as well.
In fact, you know, Martin, that modern
medicine
only came into existence when they read
the Bible and saw that they have to wash
themselves before they contaminate other
people.
That's true. All right. So, Martin,
this is actually part of the temptations
that we will have to overcome as we
read,
as we preach the three angels' messages.
That's one of them.
Because you have to be a
doer of the word and not just a lip
service provider.
We'll look at that. I think it's James
that talks about it. We'll go to James
just now. So, the first temptation
is very much part and parcel of the
three angels' messages as well.
And humanity will have to overcome
in Christ
Yeah.
where Adam and Eve failed.
You will have to.
And it's going to be hard to proclaim
the three angels' messages if you fail
at the first temptation.
As we read there in the spirit of
prophecy,
you actually have to start doing these
things, right? Otherwise, you won't be
part and parcel of the three angels'
messages or the loud cry.
Okay.
Then the devil taketh him up into the
holy city and setteth him on a pinnacle
of the temple.
So, is there religious connotation?
Yes.
Taking him to the temple.
He's taking him to the temple.
And he saith unto him,
"If thou be the son of God." Did he do
the same thing in Eden? Yes.
"Did God really say?"
He always questions something obliquely.
He's a
a sly
fox serpent.
"Cast thyself down, for it is written,
he shall give his angels charge
concerning thee.
And in their hands they shall bear thee
up, lest at any time thou dash thy foot
against the stone." Jesus said unto him,
"It is written again,
thou shalt not tempt the Lord thy God."
Martin,
this is a major temptation.
It is one that assails the whole of
humanity.
Mhm.
It is the temptation of presumption.
To presume upon God.
Yeah. Yeah. To take a position that is
not warranted in your circumstances.
You and I, I think we can safely say
are sinners. Oh, for sure. We have a
sinful nature.
And it is only in Christ that we can
overcome sin. We have no righteousness
of our own. It is only the imputed and
imparted righteousness of Christ
that gives us any stature with heaven.
So, Martin, if I'm all puffed up
and make certain claims like, "I will
forgive your sins. Confess them to me,
Martin." Is that presumption? Yep.
Of the highest order. That's blasphemy.
That's blasphemy, right?
Are there religious organizations that
do that?
Yes.
Okay. Are there religious organizations
which claim you are that once saved, you
are always saved?
Yes. Is that presumption?
That's presumption.
Are there religious organizations that
claim that humanity actually has the
power to
drive out demons, to do whatever they
want? Yeah. Because they've been given
this power. Is there such a thing as a
power religion?
Yes. Is that presumption?
They use the name of Jesus
that
apparently gives them the authority.
But then they forget that Jesus is the
authority. And they forget that there
are conditions.
The Holy Spirit which God gives to them
that obey him.
The law is no more, and their prophets
no longer find visions from the Lord.
They have made void thy law. It is time
for thee to work. Aren't those biblical
texts that need to be taken into
consideration? He who says he loves me
and keeps not my commandments is a liar
and the truth is not in him.
Anything
that presumes to take power without
fulfilling the conditions is
presumption. That's it. If you say you
love Jesus and you keep not the
commandments, you're not adhering to
what the Bible says.
Correct. If a religious system says to
you, you have to do this and this ritual
in order to be saved and you go and do
that ritual
and then you presume to be saved without
complying with the conditions,
is that presumption? Yes.
All right, Martin, how many religious
systems in the world are thus guilty of
the sin of presumption? All of them.
That's scary, Martin. That makes them
all part of Babylon, the second angel.
So, if you commit the sin of
presumption,
you accept the word of man
and the authority of man over and above
what is written,
you have committed the sin of
presumption. Yes.
In fact, if you sit in an ecumenical
council
and are prepared to compromise,
isn't that presumption? That is. Can Can
compromise get you to heaven? No.
Adam and Eve
also were presumptuous.
They thought that God won't be so harsh
because he loves them.
Yes, he loves you. So, a little sin here
and there won't keep you out of heaven,
Martin. He knows He knew their hearts.
But she ate the fruit
and she gave to Adam.
And Adam looked upon her and he thought
God would not be so harsh. He wouldn't
do that. And then he even thought that
God won't replace Eve. He will be alone.
He
All of these things went through his
mind. Don't we hear the same
things today spoken?
All right, Martin, so
the second temptation is a part of
Babylon, as we've asked before. Is it
therefore part of the three angels'
messages?
For sure.
Three temptations.
Three messages at the end.
All right, let's carry on.
Again, the devil taketh him up into an
exceedingly high mountain
and showeth him all the kingdoms of the
world and the glory of them.
And he says unto him, "All these things
will I give thee
if thou wilt fall down and worship me."
Then said Jesus unto him,
"Get thee hence, Satan, for it is
written, thou shalt worship the Lord thy
God and him only shalt thou serve."
That's why I believe this is the correct
sequence because he sends him packing
after this one. Exactly. Get thee hence,
Satan, and he recognizes him for what he
is. Yeah. The tempter, right?
He didn't say anything about Satan in
the beginning.
No.
But here he addresses him by name, his
fallen name. Yeah.
And what sin is this, Martin? This is
love of the world. And showing where
your allegiance lies.
Okay, love of the world. Now, some time
ago we did a a WhatsApp problem
where we showed a video
where many of the the music legends of
the world admit that they sold their
souls to another entity. Remember? Yep.
Why did they sell their souls to another
entity?
To be To have worldly fame. All right.
Now, why do the nations and the churches
want to be recognized
by the political and religious systems
of the world? Why do they want that
recognition?
For acceptance and popularity.
Is this Is this love of the world? 100%.
Is this loving the world more than
loving God?
Is this standing for God's principles or
capitulating to worldly principles?
100%. If we pull this through to the
third angel's message,
do not accept the mark of the beast. You
cannot accept the authority of man in
order to be able to buy and sell and do
whatever you want to get everything out
of the world that you need. Will your
heavenly Father be able to take care of
you in spite of the fact that you turn
your back on the world? He will.
But they see, the thing is popularity.
The majority.
Oh, no. It's It's just a day. All right,
let You don't have to. Just look at peer
pressure. Yeah.
What is peer pressure? Isn't it love of
the world? Yeah, 100%. To be accepted by
the world? To be accepted by your
friends?
Now, take it over to a religious
connotation.
If you want to be accepted by the
religious world, don't you have to make
compromises?
to If you want to sit in an ecumenical
council, there's compromise. You have to
compromise. If the pendulum swings
and they start saying that Sunday has to
be kept as a
day for
the world or Gaia and all of these or
even for religious reasons, that will be
the majority, the popular one.
If you sign a document called the
Charter Ecumenica
where they accept the papacy
as the moral leader,
excuse me,
haven't you then rejected God?
Doesn't it say there,
"For it is written,
thou shalt worship the Lord thy God and
him only shalt thou serve." So, Martin,
these are all very important points and
it's no good giving lip service. So,
let's just go to James. I said we would
go to James.
James.
Just after Hebrews, we should have
And turn to chapter one.
And we read from verse 13.
Because we're talking about temptations,
right?
And that you have to overcome
temptations.
Let no man say when he is tempted, "I'm
tempted of God, for God cannot be
tempted with evil, neither tempteth he
any man."
The one that does the tempting is Satan.
Yeah.
And we
Three temptations. We looked at them.
But every man is tempted when he is
drawn away of his own lust and enticed.
So, basically, if we want to rephrase
that, we can say
that man is tempted when he gives in to
his fallen nature.
So, the only way to prevent that from
happening, Martin, is if the fallen
nature is made subject to God
and dies.
The fallen nature must die. So, you're
You're an alcoholic,
but you refuse to drink.
All right?
You're a sinner, but you refuse to sin.
Now, what tells you what sin is?
The Bible does. The Bible tells you what
sin is. So, if you know what sin is, you
know how to avoid it.
You know, the lust of the eyes and all
of those things.
I like the way Job put it. I've made a
covenant with mine eyes.
Then when lust has conceived,
it brings forth sin.
In other words, when you give in
to your carnal nature,
then you start sinning.
And sin, when it is finished, brings
forth death.
Because the wages of sin is death and
that has never changed.
Christ didn't take it that away.
He didn't die for you to be a sinner.
Yeah.
All right? He didn't die to take the law
away so that you can do what you want.
Correct.
So, every good gift and every perfect
gift is from above and cometh down from
the Father of lights with whom is no
variableness, neither shadow of turning.
God doesn't change.
Nothing has changed.
So, let's drop down to verse 19.
Wherefore, my beloved brethren,
let every man be swift to hear, slow to
speak, slow to wrath.
For the wrath of man worketh not the
righteousness of God.
Wherefore, lay apart all filthiness and
superfluity of naughtiness
and receive with meekness the engrafted
word which is able to save your soul.
So, what tells you what's right and
wrong?
The word. But you must receive it. Yes.
In other words, you must allow Christ
into your heart. And then live it.
He must live it in you. He must live it
in you.
So, you must die. Yeah. Okay.
But be ye doers of the word and not
hearers only, deceiving your own selves.
Martin, if you are not a doer of the
word, but you presume to be saved
because you have taken the name of Jesus
into your mouth,
is that the sin of presumption?
Yes.
Hm? That is. Is it part of Babylon? Mhm.
Does Babylon actually teach it? Yes.
We've said it over and over. a dangerous
situation.
Okay, so what must you do?
Verse 25, but whoso looketh into the
perfect law of liberty
and continueth therein, he being not a
forgetful hearer but a doer of the work,
this man shall be blessed in his deed.
You have to do it. Yes. Can you give it
lip service?
No. What about the first temptation? Do
you have to change your lifestyle?
You have to, you cannot just say I'm
going to do it. Or Jesus doesn't expect
this of me right now. Isn't that the sin
of presumption?
You know what's another one that's
really presumptuous?
It is not salvation.
It's not salvation but the fruit
that was hanging on that tree that was
good for food and desirable for gaining
knowledge.
Martin,
did that keep them out of Eden? It did
and this was the first temptation Satan
brought against Jesus again.
All right, so then he continues and he
says, "If any man amongst you seem to be
religious and bridleth not his tongue
but deceiveth his own heart, this man's
religion is vain."
In other words, it's presumptuous.
Mhm.
And then he defines pure religion. I
find this one very interesting. Pure
religion
and undefiled before God and the Father
is this,
to visit the fatherless
and the widows in their affliction and
to keep himself unspotted from the
world.
Now Martin,
could you counterfeit that verse? Yeah,
yes.
You could, right?
Mhm.
So if you make a profession
of taking care of widows and orphans
in order to gain favor with God,
Mhm.
then that could be presumptuous.
It is because
Does that mean you mustn't take care of
widows and orphans?
No, no, that's just putting it in the
right place.
Okay.
But let's go a little bit deeper.
Who are the fatherless?
Are it Is it only those children that
have lost the physical father?
No. Or can it be humanity that has lost
contact with the Father
Yes. in heaven?
So they become objects of evangelism. So
who are the fatherless now, really? Most
of humanity.
That's it.
And the widows?
Now, a widow is a woman Is a woman not
the church also in the Bible?
Now, when does she become a widow?
When she's lost her husband.
And how many churches have lost their
husband? In other words, have lost their
connection with Christ?
Most. If you love me, keep my
commandments. If you don't, you are a
liar.
Liar.
So Martin, how many churches teach that
you don't have to keep the commandments?
Basically all. That they're abrogated.
one.
Okay. Did they Did they preach that you
had to keep the commandments?
Yes.
Have they given it up? Yes. Why would
they do a silly thing like that?
Because mother said so.
You're naughty, Martin. You're naughty.
So the widows are churches
that have become widows by rejecting
the word in its entirety, giving lip
service to some of it. And then the
final one.
And keep himself unspotted from the
world. Does that sort of fit into
everything?
temptation. Mhm?
This is all three temptations again.
Okay, let's add Let's add the first
verse of verse of chapter two as well.
My brethren, have not the faith of our
Lord Jesus Christ, the Lord of glory,
with respect of persons.
So if I obey directives of the church or
the pope
contrary to the word of God, am I
serving Jesus Christ? No, because you're
a respecter of persons and God is not.
Isn't that what we just said and spoke
about?
Okay, so can we say that the three
temptations are part and parcel of the
three angels' messages as well? I think
it's become very clear.
Let's Let's end with another quote.
If we would dwell in safety from the
noisome pestilence, if we would be
preserved from dangers seen and unseen,
we must hide in God. We must secure the
protecting care of Jesus and holy
angels. In these days of peril, the Lord
would have us walk before him in
humility.
Instead of trying to cover our sins, we
would have to confess them.
As Joshua confessed the sins of ancient
Israel.
We profess to be the depositories of
God's law.
We profess to be building up the old
waste places and to be raising up the
foundations of many generations. If this
great and solemn work has indeed been
committed to us, how important that we
depart from all iniquity.
Martin, this is a powerful quote.
It's impossible to serve God if you're
not willing to let go of the things that
can keep you out of it. All right,
Martin, so let's get to the bottom line.
If you want to get to heaven,
we have to watch the news to see what's
happening in Israel.
Well, according to
many people, yes. Yes. How many
preachers are pounding the pulpit
with that message right now? How many
evangelicals are doing that? Most. Well,
all. And it is That is where the media
leads you.
Is it not a distraction?
How many
Isn't
Isn't it not essential, Martin, that we
reach humanity as a whole and that we
preach the three angels' messages which
embrace repentance, That's it. breaking
with sin, breaking with worldliness,
warning about the real issues at hand,
making people aware of the choice which
is before them rather than watching the
news media
in order to determine your direction?
Stop getting behind either Palestine or
Israel and get behind Jesus.
All right. Now Martin, does that mean I
don't have to watch the news?
No, you just put it in the right place.
Put it in the right place.
Does this mean there is trouble upon
this earth?
Yes. Does it mean that it can escalate
into a major calamity? Yes. Does that
mean that the message must be put on
hold and put on ice until the calamity
is over or must our voices increase in
power? Especially in this time.
Especially in this time. So Martin,
whether it escalates into a third world
war or not, I do not know.
We're not prophets, but we are students
of prophecy.
Will there be a time of trouble such as
never was?
For sure. Does that mean we must stop
preaching heart change and acceptance of
Jesus to the Jew and to the Gentile?
Now's the time. So let's get it into the
right perspective.
Let's make decisions that are based on
eternal principles.
Love God and keep his commandments. This
is the whole duty of man. This is the
essence of the three angels' messages.
This is a message that must go out to
Jew and Gentile. This is a message that
must reach the entire world. And yes,
let's look at what's happening in the
world, but let's put it in the right
perspective. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
we are living in tumultuous times
and religious systems are clashing one
against the other.
No, this is as a result of propaganda,
of lies being taught from religious
centers,
of presumptive lies,
that if you do this, that, or the other,
or even destroy part of humanity, your
your path to heaven will be opened up.
This is so contrary to the doctrine of
love.
Open the eyes of humanity, no matter
what religion they belong to,
and make them realize there's no other
way
to be saved than to embrace the pure
doctrine of Jesus Christ.
This is my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.